>> Greg: WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
REMEMBER THAT.
>> Geraldo: DESPERATE TO
BROADEN THE APPEAL FROM THE
WHITE GUY BASE, THE NATIONAL
HOCKEY LEAGUE HAS BEEN FORCED TO
BACKTRACK OVER AN ADAGE POSTED
FOR UPCOMING FLORIDA JOB FAIR
AFTER RON DeSANTIS OFFICE
LANDED AS DISCRIMINATORY, THE
NOW DELETED HELP WANT TO POST,
THEY REQUIRED PARTICIPANTS IN
THE FAIR TO EITHER BE FEMALE, A
MINORITY, LGBTQIA+, A PERSON
WITH DISABILITY, OR A VETERAN.
THAT'S IT.
STRAIGHT WHITE MEN WHO DID NOT
SERVE IN THE MILITARY NEED NOT
APPLY.
RON DeSANTIS' TEAM LASTING THE
JOB FAIR EVENT SAYING "NHL, YOU
ARE OFFICIALLY ON NOTICE ABOUT
YOUR PLANNED EVENTS IN FLORIDA
UNLAWFUL DISCRIMINATION WILL BE
WILL NOT BE TOLERATED."
IT REMINDS ME OF THE IRISH NEED
NOT APPLY DAYS.
>> Judge Jeanine: IS AN
INTERESTING WITH THE WOKE, WE
KEEP GOING BACK, THAT IT IS A
BACKWARD TRAJECTORY THAT THE
WOKE WANT TO BRING US TO, WHICH
I THINK IS A TAKEDOWN OF THIS
COUNTRY.
GET RID OF EVERYTHING, GET RID
OF THE STATUES, GET RID OF THE
CONCEPTS, THE FUNDAMENTALS LIKE
LAW AND ORDER, AND WHITE MEN,
YOU ARE WORTHLESS AND YOU ARE
SUPREMACIST, BUT THE THING ABOUT
THIS IS, ONE OF THE THINGS I
WANTED TO ADDRESS IS THE WORD
ALOHA, SAID THAT WE SHOULD NOT
TO USE IT, BECAUSE WE DON'T
REALLY KNOW THE MEANING OF THE
WORD ALOHA, WHICH I ALWAYS
THOUGHT IT WAS HOLLOW, BUT IT
SIGNALS MORE AND YOU ARE
APPROPRIATING IF YOU USE THAT
WORD.
HOW CRAZY IS THIS?
>> Dana: IT'S LIKE HELLO AND
LOVE ALL THE GOOD STUFF IN ONE
WORD, BUT THEY DON'T YOU TO USE
IT.
>> Judge Jeanine: I USE TO
SWEAR IN NEWLY NATURALIZED
CITIZENS LIKE 300 PEOPLE AT THE
TIME, AND IT WAS THE HAPPIEST
DAY OF THEIR LIVES, THERE WILL
BE INDIANS, SPANISH, FRENCH, AND
EGYPTIANS AND I WOULD SAY HELLO
AND TEN DIFFERENT LINKAGES AS A
PART OF INCLUDING EVERYONE, NOT
EXCLUDING THEM.
IT'S CRAZY.
>> Geraldo: YOU CAN NO LONGER
SAY HOLA OR HOMBRE.
AND GREG GUTFELD IS THE ONLY ONE
WHO CAN'T GO TO THE JOB FAIR.
>> Greg: I AM A WHITEY.
THEY SHOULD INCLUDE THE ACTUAL
HOCKEY PLAYERS.
IT'S LIKE WHY ARE THEY JUST
EXCLUDING THE OBVIOUS EXECUTIVE
OPERATIONS.
I THINK THAT ALL OF THOSE PEOPLE
THAT YOU MENTION SHOULD BE
ELIGIBLE TO PLAY HOCKEY, AND IF
YOU DON'T DO THAT, YOU'RE A
BUNCH OF RACISTS.
>> Geraldo: MY DAUGHTER TOLD
ME THE OTHER DAY, JOEY, YOU CAN
NO LONGER SAY MASTER BEDROOM.
HAVE YOU HEARD THAT BEFORE?
>> Judge Jeanine: YES.
>> Geraldo: I'VE NEVER HEARD
THAT HEARD THAT.
>> Joey: HAVE NEVER OWNED A
HOUSE BIG ENOUGH TO HAVE ONE.
>> Greg: DID YOU EVER WORK IN
A FIELD?
>> Judge Jeanine: YOU CAN'T
SAY THAT, FIELDS.
>> Joey: THE RESPONSE IS THE
TARGET OF AUDIENCES THAT MAY NOT
BE FAMILIAR WITH HOCKEY, THERE A
LOT OF STRAIGHT WHITE DUDES IN
THE SOUTH THAT DON'T KNOW
ANYTHING ABOUT HOCKEY, AND WHILE
WE APPRECIATE THE IDEA OF SEEING
CANADIANS AND RUSSIANS FIGHT IN
AMERICAN CITIES, WE DON'T KNOW
MUCH ABOUT THE SPORT, YOU WOULD
BE SURPRISED AT THE REDNECK
INGENUITY WE CAN BRING TO THE
TABLE IF YOU WERE IN EXCLUDING
US FOR BEING STRAIGHT, WHITE,
MALE, NOT KNOWING MUCH ABOUT
YOUR SPORT.
THIS USAID TODAY THING ABOUT
WORDS, I'D RATHER NOT Y'ALL SAY
Y'ALL IF YOU ARE NOT BELOW THE
MASON DIXON OR TEXANS, HEAR ME
OUT, DON'T SAY IT AGAIN, BECAUSE
THAT'S OUR CULTURE AND WHO WE
ARE, TO US JEFF FOXWORTHY IS A
POET, NOT SOME STAND UP COMIC
SIDESHOW LIKE YOU TREAT HIM, YOU
BETTER GET MY WORDS OUT YOUR
MOUTH, OKAY, YOU HEAR ME?
ALL RIGHT, COME ON.
>> Geraldo: ALL RIGHT, OKAY.
YOU KNOW, DANA, IT IS CLUMSY,
BUT DOESN'T HOCKEY HAVE TO
BROADEN ITS APPEAL?
>> Dana: I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
NHL PRESS OFFICE IS DOING, DID
THEY MISS THE
DISNEY-FLORIDA-RON DeSANTIS
DEBACLE?
HE WINS AND IS MAKING GOOD ON
THE PROMISE, HE SAID FLORIDA IS
WHERE WOKENESS GOES TO DIE AND
IS MAKING GOOD ON THAT.
HE REMINDS ME OF THAT GROUP I
MENTION BEFORE BEFORE CALL DO NO
HARM AND MAKING SURE THAT
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS ARE NOT
BASICALLY HAVING THIS HAPPEN TO
THEM.
THEY GET ANONYMOUS TIPS FROM
PEOPLE IN THE PROFESSION SAYING,
WELL, THIS JOB OPENING JUST WENT
UP AND IT SAYS THAT BASICALLY NO
ASIANS NEED APPLY IT, THAT'S NOT
ALLOWED, SO DO NO HARM, CALLED
ESTATE, AS THEIR LAWYERS AND SAY
COMING HAVE TO TAKE IT DOWN.
AND THEY OFTEN WILL WIN, BUT
THEY WILL GO TO COURT FOR IT,
AND ANY PEOPLE LIKE THAT OR
RON DeSANTIS AND OTHERS THAT
ARE SAYING ENOUGH OF THIS.
>> Greg: HERE IS A SURPRISING
THING, WHETHER IT IS THE NHL OR
NOT OR ANY OTHER ORGANIZATION
ARE SURPRISED TO HEAR THAT IT IS
ILLEGAL.
THEY ARE LIKE, YOU CAN'T SAY YOU
WANT BLACK PEOPLE?
YOU CAN'T SAY THAT YOU WANT
HANDICAP PEOPLE?
WE ARE JUST TRYING TO BE FAIR,
THEY ARE PROBABLY -- THEY HAVE
NO IDEA IT'S DISCRIMINATION.
>> Geraldo: